ces vingt dossiers qui animent les
débats depuis des années et qui a pris
un virage important le 28 novembre 2010
est à ouagadougou le président emmanuel
macron prend un engagement celui de
restituer des oeuvres d'art à l'afrique
moins de quatre mois après le président
français demande un rapport sur le sujet
document remis fin 2018 par deux
universitaires bénédicte savoy eiffel
winstar parler de restitution en 2018
c'est donc rouvrir à la fois le ventre
de la machine coloniale et le dossier de
la mémoire doublement effacer des
européens et des africains d'aujourd'hui
les uns ignorant pour la plupart comment
se sont constitués leur prestigieux
musées les autres peinant à retrouver le
fils d'une mémoire interrompue
le rapport détaille ainsi la façon dont
ces oeuvres ont été subtilisés lors de
la colonisation
les soldats n'hésitant pas à l'époque à
amasser des butins de guerre des oeuvres
qui se retrouvent désormais dans les
musées notamment en europe celui du quai
branly à paris est sans doute l'un de
ceux qui en accueille le plus sous
l'appellation des arts premiers on y
trouve des oeuvres originaires de pays
tels que le sénégal la guinée encore le
bénin des collections entières qui
pourrait à terme être rendus à leurs
pays d'origine pour les auteurs du
rapport ces transferts sont un premier
pas vers une nouvelle relation entre la
france et l'afrique
les restitution des biens culturels
africains et initie donc une nouvelle
économie de la relation dont les effets
ne saurait se limiter à l'espace
culturel ou à celui des échanges
muséographique ces restitutions ont en
fait déjà commencé ces derniers mois
edouard philippe et franck riester alors
respectivement premier ministre et
ministre de la culture avait fait des
annonces en ce sens c'est destitution et
fait partie d'un nouveau nouvelle
politique des changes finalement qui
passe par des restitutions transfert de
propriété mais aussi d' à circulation
des oeuvres de près d'établissements
d'exposition ou de réflexion plus
globale sur les politique muséale
le projet de loi présenté en conseil des
ministres doit inscrire ce procédé dans
le marbre législatif cela permettra
alors d'examiner
le détail les oeuvres concernées et leur
potentiel renvoi en afrique
mais ces transferts sont contestés par
certains c'est le cas par exemple de
l'ancien président du musée du quai
branly qui avait eu des mots assez durs
sur le rapport publié par le binôme sa
voix ça ce rapport est un cri de haine
contre le concept même de mu est
considérée comme une invention
occidentale comme un lieu quasi criminel
dans lequel les objets sont plus mais
déshabiller où on leur retire leur magie
il y à quelque chose d'assez pervers à
prétendre que l'universalité des oeuvres
d'art n'est pas une bonne chose
d'autres redoutent une politisation de
la question dans une période déjà en
proie aux débats frénétique sur les
figures historiques
reste que ces oeuvres pour la plupart
dérobé pendant la colonisation
représente une part non négligeable du
patrimoine culturel de ces pays
africains
selon le rapport publié en 2010 8 90
mille oeuvres pourraient être concernés
le débat est donc loin d'être terminée